and Israel says Rockets have been fired
from Southern Lebanon let's go to Hoda
Abdul Hamid who is in East Jerusalem for
us what more do we know about these
Rockets
well we're not getting very much detail
from the Israeli Army what we do know is
that Rockets were fired from Southern
Israel into from Southern Lebanon rather
into Northern Israel it happened quite
quickly in a short span of time in about
10 minutes we also do know that some of
those Rockets were intercepted by the
Iron Dome air defense system that Israel
possesses and we also know and that's
coming out from the uh actually Lebanese
state agency that Israel has retaliated
using artillery fire into Southern
Israel we don't have more details than
that but we haven't heard any reports of
casualties we've been also monitoring
the Israeli media that has been rolling
on this news for the past hour or so
what they are waiting for is to hear
from prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu
he is supposed to convene with his
security cabinet in the coming hours
this would be the first time he actually
convenes with the security cabinet since
February uh he will have to sit at the
table with his defense minister with
whom he has a very bad relationship at
the moment and maybe after that we'll
hear a more uh complete statement about
maybe what Israel is planning to do in
the coming hours or in the coming days
but at the moment it appears that the
situation along that border is calm and
we haven't heard any more reports of any
kind of fire in either direction
I'll I'll just mention a wire that's
just flashed and uh it says the Israeli
defense officials say that the military
is still assessing the situation after
those rocket strikes from Lebanon so
yeah pretty much status quo for the time
being we've also had tensions rising in
occupied East Jerusalem as well
yes absolutely it's been actual tensions
are rising in that focal point which is
the AXA most compound and actually
inside the atmosphere two uh Early
Mornings in a row uh the Israeli Army
has actually stormed into the mosque
trying to remove worshipers from inside
that mosque uh using a quite
heavy-handed ways using stunt grenades
tear gas the rubber tipped bullets so
all sorts of things and those pictures
had gone absolutely viral and have
infuriated uh Palestinians even more
because you have to remember that
tensions are always simmering in
occupied East Jerusalem because of many
reasons the house demolition house
evictions all sorts of constraints the
Palestinians are living under on a daily
basis but during this month during
Ramadan this is a time where people go
to the mosque where people stay in the
mosque the Israeli Army stormed Freedom
twice two days in a row evicting those
people also hitting and slapping while
escorting Palestinian women and children
out of the complex certainly that has
created a lot of tension has infuriated
Palestinians in Gaza has infuriated
Palestinians living across the border in
Lebanon and has infuriated also many
Muslims around the world so all this
comes together really at a time of
extreme tension that could really erupt
in any direction this is how things
happen here and it puts prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu under a lot of
pressure especially that he has his own
domestic issues at the moment okay thank
you for that update Abdul Hamid
therefore in East Jerusalem we will
indeed keep across the story for you if
there are any more developments we will
bring them to you